speaker nancy pelosi is making masks
mandatory on the house floor after yet
another congressman tested positive
for the coronavirus texas republican
louis gomer who's been adamantly opposed
to wearing a mask
is a close ally of president trump in
fact he was about to travel with the
president when he tested positive
paula reid reports from the white house
together we will end the plague from
china we will defeat the virus
speaking in west texas president trump
made no mention of the texas
representative who was expected to be
with him
just before republican representative
louie gomer was supposed to travel on
air force one with the president
he tested positive for kovid 19.
politico
reports after the announcement a gomer
staffer contacted them
saying the congressman requires a full
staff in the office
and that they are berated for wearing
masks gohmert has often been seen
not wearing a face covering wednesday
gohmert made the unsubstantiated
suggestion that his illness may have
been
caused by the few occasions he did wear
a mask
i know you know moving the mask around
getting just right
i'm bound to put some some virus on the
mask that i
sucked in that's most likely what
happens but there is no evidence to
support that claim
in fact medical experts say wearing
masks helps stop the spread of the virus
on tuesday gohmert was seen walking
alongside attorney general bill barr
neither man was wearing a mask the
attorney general has so far
tested negative gohmert's diagnosis
prompted house speaker nancy pelosi to
issue a mask
mandate for the house as a sign of
respect for the health
safety and well-being of others but
majority leader mitch mcconnell does not
intend to do the same for the senate
it appears not to be necessary since
everybody seems to be doing it
congress also remains divided on a
second round of economic relief
even as enhanced unemployment benefits
are set to expire
friday i would say there's not an
agreement on anything
republicans have floated the idea of a
narrow short-term negotiated deal
but house speaker nancy pelosi has
rejected that she says that republicans
put them
up against the wall by refusing to
negotiate for two months
but in a peace offering of sorts the
white house has offered congress
additional testing capability now that
over a dozen lawmakers have contracted
the virus
anthony paula reed thanks paula